في خطوه لافته قال رئيس تركيا رجب طيب
اردوغان انه قد يعيد النظرات في العلاقات
العرائس السوري بشار الاسد بعد الانتخابات
الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه المقرر اجرائها في
تركيا في يونيو العمل مقبل وردا على سؤال
حول احتمال عقده لقاء مع الرئيس السوري
قال اردوغان انه لا يوجد السياق او خلاف
ابديه سياسه وكان اردوغان اكد شهرا الماضي
انا خيار لقاء الرئيس السوري مطروح عندما
يحين الوقت المناسب لذلك مشينا الى ان
هناك محادثات تجري بين البلدين على مستوى
المنخفض جاء ذلك في ظل السلسله التصريحات
تركيه على مدى الاشهر الماضيه عن امكانيه
اعاده العلاقات مع روسيا واهميه ذلك على
صعيدي ملف اللاجئين السوريين في تركيا
والذي اخذ حيزا كبيرا من الجدل في منافسات
الانتخابات التركيه المقبله خبره راوا ان
الموقفه التركي في شاني عوده التواصل مع
النظام السوري لتطبيع العلاقه بين البلدين
بانه ليس جديده معتبرين ان هذا الخطاب
هدفه كسب شارع التركي وقطع الطريق على
المعارضه التركيه التي تستخدم ورقه
السوريين للضغط على الحكومه وتقليب الشارع
ضد اردوغان لذا وفق تحليلات سياسيه انتهجت
انقره سياسه مختلفه نحو التصفير المشاكل
واخر محطه في هذا التحرك كانت مع دمشق
كورقه انتخابيه
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من الرياض
العميد اسعد الزعبي المحلل العسكري
ولستراتجي وروسي السوري عفوا اهلا بك ومن
اسطنبول دكتور بكرا مهدي اسطنبول للفكر
اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام واسمحوا لي ان ابدا
من اسطنبول معك دكتور بكير دكتور بكير في
الواقعه تصريحات التي تدعو ل همم تقريبا
المسافات بين حكومتي دمشق وانقره ليست
بالجديده ولكن ان يصرح الرئيس اردوغان
بالقول بانه قد يجلس مع بشار الاسد بعد
الانتخابات لماذا ربط هذا التقارب
بالانتخابات
مساء الخير تحياتي يعني اولا لابد الاشاره
الى نقطه هامه ذكرتها قبل قليل
تركيا ااه يعني تربط علاقتها مع نظام
الاسد
بشروط وليست بانها والدليل على ذلك عندما
يقول عندما همم تكون الوقت المناسب او
تتوفر الشروط والمناخ المناسب لهذا اللقاء
طبيعي وقبل ايام كان هناك ايضا تصريح
لوزير الخارجيه في نفس المستوى حيث قال
اذا توفرت الشروط اللازمه من المحادثات
الاستخباراتيه سوف تكون الى همم تتحول الى
دبلوماسيه بمعنى اخر ايضا يعني هذه الشروط
في حاله تحققت ان كان وزير الخارجيه او
رئيس الجمهوريه
سوف يلتقيان مع نظام الاسد في الاشهر
القادمه
الرئيس التركي بموضوع الانتخابات في
تصريحاته المتعلقه بهذا التقارب هذا
السؤال
قال اذا كان هذا سوف تكون بعد الانتخابات
لك لم يقل يعني بعد الانتخابات بمعنى اخر
ليس هو مستجدا في هذا الامر ثانيا يعني
الان لن تتوفر الشروط التي هي ما زالت بين
الطرفين بعيدا الان همم وهذا يعني كمان في
نفس الوقت همم يعني تركيا همم جده يعني
ليست فقط كما يدعى من اجل الانتخابات لا
بالعكس وبعد الانتخابات ممكن ان تكون
استمرار ولقاء مع نظام الاسد ولكن
حضرتك
يعني سقف زمني وضعه رئيس التركي ليس الا
او انه كما يذهب مراقبون بقراءاتهم بان
زوج الانتخابات في مصر هكذا تصريحات تتعلق
بهذا التقارب هو رساله من الداخل وبان
الكلمه المفتاح
للداخل هي العلاقات او تمثيل العلاقات مع
سوريا
الوقائع والتي تعكس الحقيقه يعني لا اتحدث
باعتقادات او احتمالات يعني الواقعه
الاولى والتي تنطلق من خطه وزاره الخارجيه
التركيه او القاده التركيه عندما قالت
نريد ان تكون صفر مشاكل تحقيق صفر مشاكل
لو عدنا الى الوراء قليل يعني العلاقه ما
بين تركيا والامارات او السعوديه او مصر
صحيح كانت هناك علاقه يعني مقطوعه او نقول
درجه حراره هذه العلاقات كانت 10 تحت
الصفر او 20 تحت الصفر بينما عندما نتحدث
عن العلاقه بين تركيا وبين النظام التركي
او بين النظام الاسد فالحقيقه يعني نقول
الحراره 273 وربما اكثر وهذا بعلم
الفيزياء يعني عليه تتجمد كل الاشياء
وبالتالي عندما يتحدث عن اي عوده للعلاقه
فهي محفوظه ليس فقط من الانتخابات محفوظه
بالمخاطر والمخاطر الكبيره جدا
امثله على ذلك يعني عندما نقول ان همم
يعني همم الرئيس اردوغان اعاده علاقتي مع
باشا اسد ماذا تريد من بشار الاسد اذا كان
باشا الاسد بحد ذاته هو يعيش على اجهزه
الانتعاش مع الروس او مع ايران فماذا تريد
منهم ماذا تريد هل تستطيع ان تقول ان تظن
ان باشا الاسد يمكن ان يرفع قيمه الليره
التركيه او يقلل
التضخم المالي او يمكن حتى ان ان يعني
يفصل علاقته معدد يعني اذا عندما تحدث عن
قضيه عودته همم لا بد ان نقول ان قضيه
تتعلق بالانتخابات اولا واخرا وخاصه اننا
هذه يعني هذه الشعارات او هذه ال- ال- ال-
ال- الاشارات التي انطلق يمكن تركيا انما
انطلقت بالمرحله الحرجه وهي مرحله يعني
الاشاره او البدء بالتحضير للانتخابات
واعتقد ان يعني ما قامت به القياده
التركيه حاول ربط هذا بالانتخابات قادما
او حتى بدايه تصريحات الرئيس التركي
بدل الاشاره للانتخابات كان خطر كبير وهو
يعني يعطي نقطه ضعف للرئيس اردوغان امام
معارضه التركيه يعني عندما تحدث تماما
يعطي رساله للمعارضه انني انا يعني اصبحت
ضعيفا وبتالي حتى اتقوا اتقوى بباشا الاسد
وبشار الاسد لا يمكن ان يقوي باشي لا
يستطيع ان يقوي نفسه كيف يمكن ان يقوي
يعني الرئيس الاخير الرئيس التركي اذا
عندما نتحدث عن هذه الواقع نتحدث عن واقع
موجوده فعلا بالواقع العملي نقول لا
يستطيع ربما يستطيع برشلونه ان يقدم له
تركيا المزيد من شحنات المخدرات الا اذا
كانت تركيا بحاجه لهذه الشحنات فيمكن ان
نقول ان هناك قد يسر يعني يعني قد تكون
تركيه بحاجه الى نظام بشار الاسد اما
عندنا نتحدث حقيقه عن الانتخابات فل حديث
كبير جدا وطويل» الى ليس فقط باراده
الانتخابات قادما يعني لا نقول ان الرئيس
اردوغان سيلتقي مع بشار الاسد فيما بعد
الانتخابات ان هناك اذا علامات استفهام
كثيره حقيقه يمكن ان توضع بقضيه ما بعد
انتخابات او قبل انتخابات وبالتاكيد طبعا
يجب ان لنا يعني بعد حديث ممكن نحدث عن
قضيه اعاده اللاجئين وكان اللاجئين ليس
ملكا لاردوغان وليس ملك لبشار الاسد حتى
نقول اعاده اللاجئين او عدم اعاده
اللاجئين واساس عشان اصدق اعتقد الشروط
التي طرحها بين الاسد هي حقيقه شروط يعني
ليس لا تليق حتى بتركيا وعندما تحدث تركيه
عن قضيه اعادت علاقته مع بشار اعتقد يجب
ان يتذكر ان النظام السوري رفض النظام
السوري الضعيف النظام السوري الغير معترف
به شرعيا النظام السوري الذي يعني يعيش عن
عائشه الروسي الايراني رفض ان يعيد
العلاقه مع تركيا يعني انظر الى هذا الحد
واعتقد ان هذا يجب ان يعني يصب ليس فقط في
وزاره الخارجيه او رئاسه الجمهوريه يجب ان
يصب حتى بحزب العداله والتنميه التركي
يذهب لابعدنا ذلك وهو يقول بان لي تركي
شروط ولكن قبل هذه الشروط فقط ان هو ذات
التعليق على مستوى العلاقات الاقتصاديه
دكتور ما كان لن اتوقف على تبادل همم
المخدرات كما تفضل عميد زعبيل الحديث الا
اذا كان لك تعليق حول هذا الموضوع هو
ذكرها تهكم على مستوى التبادل الهزيل بين
الدولتين لديك تعليق دكتور
الطبيعي يعني اولا لابد اذا بتسمحوا لي
يعني اولا اقول اردوغان لا يعول على الاسد
في نجاحها في الانتخابات وليست لها علاقه
من بعيد او قريب حتى وحتى على المعارضه
التركيه المعارضه التركيه الضعيفه وخاسره
في هذه الانتخابات انا اعطيكم من الان لسه
للانتخابات اكثر من سبعه اشهر اقول همم
تحدي بان الرئيس اردوغان ناجح في هذه
الانتخابات
وبكل من الجوله الاولى همم مهما كان همم
المرشح الاخر
لان تصريحات السابقه لاردوغان تضعنا في
اطار كونه لن يقدم نفسه لترشح جديد الا
اذا كان لديك معلومات اخرى دكتور باكير
ايه يعني اولا بالنسبه لهذا الموضوع
تقريبا منتهي بالنسبه للانتخابات لذلك
اردوغان لا يعول اذا كانت يعني الاسد او
غير الاسد او اي دوله اخرى يمكن يجب النظر
الى نقطه هامه عندما تركيا تقول
النظام او الاسد هنا ليست بمعنى فتح
العلاقه المباشره مع النظام
تخلي عن الشروط التي كانت وما زالت همم
تدعى بين الحين والاخر مع المسؤولين همم
الاتراك للطرف الثاني وحتى هناك كان وفد
قبل شهر تقريبا من المقرر ان يذهب الى
دمشق التشاور
همم طلب همم القياده التركيه من هؤلاء بان
لا يذهب هذا الوفد وكان وفد مدني وسياسي
متشكل من همم حوالي 13 شخص ومن
عده فئات من الشعب ومن المؤسسات المدنيه
ومن الاحزاب السياسيه
بمعنى اخر يعني تركيا لها شروط وهذه شروط
اذا لن تتوفر لن يكون حتى ذهاب وليس
اعتقال سيف يقول لك بانه
شروط يقول لك بالعكس يقول لك بانه النظام
السوري همم في احلى وفي اصعب ظروفه هو من
رفض العوده لتطبيع العلاقات مع تركيا
فحضرتك تقول بانه العكس هو صحيح همم شروط
تركيا هي التي ستضع على الطاوله كيف ذلك
ما هي هذه الشروط
يعني
تركيا قالت هي سوف تريد ان تكون يعني
اهمها العلاقه اييي يعني ذهاب الى المرحله
الانتقاليه الدستور والتي هي من اهم
النقاط التي كانت وفقا مؤتمر يعني قرارات
جينيف 22 54 واضح لا اريد ان ادخل في
تفاصيل هذه القرارات ولكن واضحه جدا
وتركيا قالت عندما التقى وزير الخارجيه مع
وزير الخارجيه السوري قال له يعني لابد
الذهاب الى هذه همم همم
قرارات وعلى الاساس نحن على استعداد
توفير الفرصه الاولى
حرفين
لمعارضه السوريه
همم النقاط التي يضعها الجانب التركي
واضحه ومن ثم تتحدث عن فتره الانتقاليه عن
دستور السوري همم خليني اخذ راي همم
العميد زعبي عميد زعبي هل هذه شروط التي
ستقرب او ستبعد المسافات بين دمشق وانقره
تعتقد
تماما للدكتور بكير يعني انا من بدا بشروط
هو النظام يعني حديث همم فيصل مقداد قبل
الفتره عندما يعني بدات الاشارات تخرج من
الخارجيه التركيه باتجاه اللقاء مع هذا
النظام ال- ال- ال- البائد بدمشق بدا يعني
فيصل مقداد يصرح تماما على الاعلام يقول
نحن لا نريد هذه العلاقه ولا نعود تركيه
قبل ان او يعني تنسحب من الشمال السوري
وبعد يعني بدا النظام حتى بتصلي حتى نفسه
يعني والسؤال مطروح يعني يجب ان يجرح
حقيقه الان عندما بدات قضيه الانتخابات في
تركيا لماذا المعارضه التركيه تريد الذهاب
لدمشق والرئيس التركي ايضا يريد الحديث او
التقاء مع بشار الاسد يعني هل يا ترى
تركيا الدوله العظمى التي نراها ونعرفها
هل هي هل هي اصبحت في هذا الحجم حتى تكون
بحاجه الى بشار الاسد سواء كان النظام
التركي الحالي او المعارضه القادمه
وبالتالي هذه الحديث لم يبدا او لم يعني
يخرج العلن الا في فتره الحديث عن
الانتخابات وهناك سؤاله او ك- كبير يجب ان
ان نطرحه لماذا عندما كانت تركيا قويه
وكانت تهدد نظام بشار الاسد او حافظ الاسد
لم يكن هناك اي علاقه بالانتخابات التركيه
مع النظام اليوم النظام في في اضع حالته
اليوم ارجو الجميع يربط يعني مستقبله يعني
المجازيه نقول مستقبل همم نجاحي في
الانتخابات ببشار الاسد سواء كان المعارضه
وحتى النظام يعني النظام التركي عندما
تحدث ايضا كانت المعارضه تقول نحن سنذهب
الى دمشق وبالتالي يعني ساستثني قضيه
اللاجئين على جانب يعني اقول ليست القضيه
قضيه اللاجئين السوريين انما اذا كان
النظامين المتنافسين في الانتخابات
التركيه هكذا يتحدثون فماذا جرى في تركيا
حتى وصلنا الى هذه المرحله لن نقول نحن في
حاله الاسد وكما ذكرت يعني يعود الذكر
بشار الاسد يعيش على الانعاش لم يعد هناك
نظام في سوريا حتى نرتبط فيه او حتى نراه
عليه
يطرح سؤال مشروعه يقول ما الذي حدث بداخله
التركي حتى تتسابق المعارضه كما النظام
على محاوله تتقارب من النظام السوري
همم تسويه ملفات عديده لمحاوله ظفر باكثر
عدد من همم الناخبين همم او من الداعمين
على الاقل فدخل تركي
سيدتي العزيزه للاسف الشديد ضيفك ما يقوله
يتناقط ما يطرحه مره اخرى يعني اولا اقول
بشكل واضح تركيا في موقف قوي ان كانت
بالنسبه لسوريا او بالنسبه للعالم بنسبه
الدوله اقليميه وهي لا تحتاج لا الى نظام
الاسد ولا الى حتى سوريا ولكن هناك شروط
تركيا الان تلعب دورا مهما في العالم لها
دور اقليمي مهم جدا ان كانت المصالحه بين
اوكرانيا وروسيا ان كانت الامور المتعلقه
بين الدول وهي تريد ان تكون يعني دوله
اقليميه بامتياز ولكن عندما تطرح لماذا
اذا المشاكل ما زالت بينكم وبين سوريا
وبينكم وبين العراق بينكم وبين مصر بينكم
وبين اسرائيل بينكم وبين اليونان فهذه
الشروط عندما تقول تركيا نحن على استعداد
لا تعني بانها تقبل بهذه الشروط كما يدعى
وخاصه عندما يعني اعطيكم مثالا عندما يقول
المقداد همم تطلب من تركيا انسحاب هل
تنسحب تركيا فعلا هل من الممكن ان تنسحب
بهذا الطلب همم ان كان وزير خارجيه وحتى
الرئيس السوري النظام النظام السوري هل هل
بهذه السهوله تقبل هذه الشروط تركيا
السياسه وابداع فاذا فاذا تكون دائما بعض
الامور الدول التي يعني اقصد الولايات
المتحده تركيا انجلترا
فلابد ان تكون تركيا ليست عاجزه امامه
بالعكس تقول نحن شروطنا هنا واضحه ونحن
على استعداد في اللقاء ولكن عندما يحين
الوقت والمكان وليست نحن نعم نعم نحن نريد
ولكن من اجل الشعب السوري ليس من اجل هذا
النظام القادم ليس من اجل ارضاء الاسد من
اجل العالم كله عميد
مصالحه بين مكونات الشعب السوري وليس لكي
يستمر
تركيا تاتي لصالح الداخل السوري والشعب
السوري ما التعليقك في هذا الموضوع
طبعا هذا يعني للاسف يعني يعني دعيني اقول
هذا غير صحيح يعني لكن انا ردا على كلمه
التناقض انا اقول يعني بدايه حديث قلت لا
يمكن تشبيه العلاقه ما بين تركيا وكل من
الامارات او السعوديه ومصر كانت الحراره
ناقص عشره تحت الصفر بينما بين تركيا
والنظام الاسد كانت 200 93 لا يمكن
المقارنه لا انا انا انكر دور تركيا بقضيه
اوكرانيا او اذربيجان انما اقول حاليا
لماذا هذا التسابق ما بين ال- ال- يعني
الاخلاف او نقول الاحزاب التركيه التي
تريد الانتخابات لماذا هذا التسابق باتجاه
العوده الى بشار الاسد الضعيف اللي
المنهار اقتصاديا في حين انه عندنا لعام
1999 كانت تركيا تهدد بشار الاسد او تهدد
حافظ الاسد ان دمشق خلال دقائق اذا هل هو
ضعف تركي او او ماذا يمكن تفسيرها اما عن
قضيه يعني العلاقه همم اللاجئين او قضيه
مصالحات فاعتقد ان نحن لا نريد ان نصالح
الاسد الذي قتل من يومنا وانتم لست معنيين
بقضيه الشرح يعني انتم لا تنثرون على
الصلح ولا ايتم ولا انتم معيين ولا انتم
اسهم بموضع الوساطه بيننا وبينه احنا لا
يمكن ان نقبل به ولا يمكن ان نعود اليه
ولا يمكن ان نقبل به رئيسا سوريا طالما كل
العالم رفض شرعيته فانتم تريدون الان
بوجود الانتخابات او بحجه الانتخابات
عندما تتحدثون تريد ان تلتقون بيوتكم
تعطونيو شرعيا وهو شرعيته مرفوضه من كل
العالم وانتم اول ما نكر شعريه هذا الذي
اذا هناك هنا التناقض وليست تناقض بحديث
عندما تتحدث عن قضيه درجه الحراره بينها
وبين الدول الاخرى انا لا اكل لا انكر ان
لدي دور في قضيه تصدير الحبوب او او
تقريبا المسافه ما بين روسيا اوكرانيا
انما اليوم تركيا يعني ما تتحدث بهذه
الطريقه وترته تحط رهان على على هذا
الحصان الخاسر يعني اعتقد هناك كثير من
علامات الاستفهام يجب ان تقل هل بشار
الاسد له دور عالميه حتى نقول يجب يعني
الينا كمعارضه تركيا
والاخرون نعيد دمشق
فقط يقول بانه هناك توجه تركي لتصفير
المشاكل همم حتى يكون هناك حضور دولي
لتركيا بشكل اا
جديد ربما يقول دكتور بكراتشان ما رايك
بمشاكل صحيح تصوير مشاكل مع الامارات تصير
مشاكل مع السعوديه مع مصر بورما مع
اليونان لكن ليست ما عندهم مع بشار الاسد
القاتل المجرم باعتراف كل دول العالم الذي
كل 132 دوله رفضت شرعته واول الدول هي
تركيا واول الدول المتضرره من النظام
السوري هي تركيا النظام كان يدعم حزب
العمال كل سنه وما زال يدعمه اليوم
تفجيرات التي تركيه اليس من وراءها هي
النظام الاسد المخدرات التي تصل الى تركيا
وراها بشل الاسد اذا هذا الكلام مرفوض
حاليا جمله وتفصيلا ان نقول عوده النظام
التركي او حتى المعارضه التركيه الى بشار
الاسد عندما تقول لمعارضه فانا وعندما
يقول النظام التركي اتهموه بالخيانه
الدكتور بكير ما رايك في هذا التناقص كما
يرى ضيفي من الحسابات التركيه على الاقل
التي تضعها انقر على الطاوله في الفتره
الاخيره
انا قبل قليل قلت واعيد مره اخرى يعني
عندما طالبت وفود الذهاب كانت الحكومه لم
تقبل في الذهاب حتى بالزياره يعني بمعنى
اخر ليس هذا التوجه
يعني
قبول شرعيه نظام الاسد وهناك تصريحات
عديده للرئيس الاسد للرئيس اردوغان مرات
عديده نحن لا لا يعني باننا اذا التقينا
نقبل بشرعيه همم الاسد وهذا مرفوض نزل
البدايه وما زادت مرفوضه ولكن هناك شروط
كما شرط واذا كان كما يبدع من اجل
الانتخابات كان كان همم بامكان ان يقول
نحن على استعداد في اي لقاء لكن لن يقول
الا بعد بعد الانتخابات بمعنى اخر هو يرفض
ان تكون لها رابط بين هذه اللقاء التي سوف
تكون وبين الانتخابات ايضا واضح جدا
همم
دكتور بكير هو اللي ربطها الرئيس التركي
هو الذي ربط في تصريحاته هذا التقارب
بالانتخابات ومن هنا اتى عنوان هذا الملف
للنقاش على كل هذه الاسئله
قال بعد الانتخابات قد اجلس مع الرئيس
السوري بشار الاسد قد يجمعنا لقاء بعد
الانتخابات ولكن كل هذه الاسئله قد نجد
اجابه عليها بعد هذه الانتخابات
عندما سئل من طرف الصحفيين همم انت قلت
باننا نستطيع ان نلتقي مع الاسد متى سوف
تكون هذا اللقاء هذه المره الاخيره يعني
قبل يومين عندما كان راجع من اندونيسيا
فقال هذه لن تكون بهذه السرعه يعني الناس
بتنتظرين طالما
يعني يكون الاوان متى فقال دي ممكن تكون
بعد الانتخابات اذا ليس لها علاقه
بالانتخابات هو قالها اذا صار اذا هذا
اللقاء سوف تكون بعد الغابات
سننتظر
اول شكرا جزيل شكرا على ان نلتقي في
لقاءات اخرى من اسطنبول دكتور بكيره مهدي
اسطنبول للفكر شكرا كذلك لحظرتك من
الرياضه العميد اسعد الزعبي المحلل
العسكري
والاستراتيجيه السوري شكرا لك
[موسيقى]